Bella Hadid is showing a whole lot of  skin in her racy new flare magazine  feature I mean it's so crazy to me the  19 year old is on the cover of the  magazine Oprah issue but it's the photos  inside that prove Bella isn't afraid to  get a little wet and wild check out this  pic the model lounging in a pretty  see-through wet Calvin Klein tee leaving  little to the imagination and here she's  a totally topless I guess I'm doing  something right we also get a couple  shots of Bella covering up with a  strategically placed but enough and a  white denim jacket I worked really hard  and I'm just really happy it's big muff  for the Hadid beauties Bella's big says  Gigi also landed a major magazine cover  a Harper's Bazaar